Speaker 1: So dozens of you e-mailed me over the
weekend saying I have to see this segment of Fox
News propagandist Tucker Carlson sort of bemoaning
that he is going to find the new way that Eminem's
are anthropomorphized in commercials, less
arousing and less of a turn on to him.
I, as many of you know, I kind of don't pay
much attention to the news over the weekend.
And then Sunday evening, I'll start picking out
stories for the Monday show. And I didn't know
what to expect based on all of the emails I had
from people saying, check out the tucker thing.
It is downright creepy and bizarre. Now let me
give you guys some context. Eminem's announce?
I don't know. Do people even do I need to explain
Eminem's Eminem's or this chocolate candy? There's
regular Eminem's, there's peanut M&Ms, there's
peanut butter, Eminem, you know, all these
different kinds. And in the commercials, they are
anthropomorphized, meaning they are drawn with
eyes and shoes and legs and all this different
stuff. Apparently, among other changes, the brown
Eminem is going to be redrawn as slightly less
stereotypically attractive. I don't even know what
to call it. Like Brown, Eminem's high heels will
be slightly lower it. And Tucker believes that
this is part of the big culture war that he thinks
is being fought, and he's angry that Brown Eminem
won't be as attractive to him. This
is beyond belief. Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: Finally, tonight we don't usually
give story tips to NPR, but here's a story
they might want to cover pretty soon in Dallas
will well, Eminem's The Candy Company has just
announced that it's redesigning its cartoon
characters to be more gender inclusive,
which. I bet she didn't think Eminem's were
pushing intolerance, but they were. They've
been changed, you're seeing the changes
right now on your screen. The green Eminem,
you will notice, is no longer wearing sexy
boots. Now she's wearing sensible sneakers.
Speaker 1: That's going to make it really, really
tough for Tucker to enjoy looking at these images
because it's just not attractive enough to him.
Speaker 3: Why the change? Well, according to
Eminem's quote, we all win when we see more
women in leading roles. Because leading women
do not wear sexy boots, leading women wear frumpy
shoes, the frumpy or the better. That's the rule.
The other big change is that the brown Eminem has,
quote, transitioned from high stilettos to lower
block heels. So less sexy. That's progress. Eminem
will not be satisfied until every last cartoon
character is deeply unappealing and totally
androgynous. Until the moment you wouldn't
want to have a drink with any one of them,
that's the goal when you're totally turned off.
We've achieved equity. They've won. Meanwhile,
in a nod to the burgeoning wellness movement,
the Orange M&M will quote, acknowledge and embrace
his anxiety. And actually, if you look at him,
the Orange Eminem does appear very anxious. Maybe
he doesn't like all the ugly new shoes he sees
around him. Maybe he liked the sexy boots.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Does anybody else find it
strange that Tucker Carlson is so keyed into
how attractive he finds anthropomorphized
chocolate candy to be? Does anybody
care about this? And in all, see?
Close your eyes for a moment. Let me take you on
a journey. Close your eyes. It's 2017. Trump has
just come to power, and I tell you about a segment
in which Tucker Carlson is bemoaning the fact that
the brown Eminem is now being anthropomorphized
in a less appealing way to him sexually. You would
have said, David, that's an SNL skit. That's
SNL 2017. You would have said that's a parody,
but it is actually now the culture war that they
are fighting. And some people see this and they
actually get angry. Hey, man, did you see what
they're doing with Eminem's man frickin? Let's go,
Brandon, Joe Biden, these people communist. It's
terrible liberal. It's what they've done with
Eminem is is just unconscionable. Yeah, yeah. I
saw and green also remember the shoes the green
used up. What is wrong with these people?
But they don't have anything else. I mean,
we watched Joni Ernst earlier struggle to name
anything that Republicans would do if they won
in November, and they may win. Republicans may win
the Senate, they may win the House, and they can't
articulate anything they would do. I guess maybe
Tucker would want to bring back hot brown Eminem,
but that's not really much of a policy
that does anything for working people.
And it is. I was like, No, my audience is
exaggerated. This is not what the clip was.
And it's exactly what the clip was,
and it's extraordinarily disturbing.